hello everyone I hope everyone is having
a great Saturday and I hope you enjoyed
yesterday's dream those of you who
haven't and don't know who the winners
of the giveaway are I will put a list of
the winners in the description below so
you can see who won the Amazon gift
cards and the championship chess set
about this game well the world junior
championship came to an end and in the
end Norway now has two world champions
Magnus Carlsen as the official world
champion in classical chess and Ariane
Terry the junior world champion and
those of you who were hoping pregnant
Landa will win win win the entire event
well this time young probably didn't
break any nor I didn't break any records
but he did get his first Grand Master
norm and with a would half point behind
starry Indian he finished in fourth
place but he played a he played a
spectacular tournament and I'm sure I'm
sure he still has plenty to go for but
this game it was played in round 8 re
and terry has the black pieces against
Grigory operon and the operon is a very
strong Russian Grand Master he's rated
above 2600 I think it's twenty six
hundred and six so Tori has the black
pieces against a higher rate your
opponents definitely a difficult task
for any any chess player and Terry is
actually the 12th Grandmaster Norway has
produced and he's actually the third
youngest player ever to win the Norway
Championship Atari went to Norway
championship in 2015
younger than him were Simon Augustine
and the Magnus Carlsen who owned it at
the age of 15
Atari was 16 at the time so let's see
this game and for those of you who play
play the caro-kann this will be quite a
treat we have a four by Oberon and c6
bite re d 4 D 5 and E 5 now the advanced
variation of the caro-kann and here you
have two types of players those that
will play c5 here and go in some sort of
French variation being a tempo down and
those like Tariq who will play Bishop to
f5 who are not afraid of the bayonet
as that is exactly what operon goes for
he plays G for the bed the bayonet
variation of the caro-kann defense
Bishop to g6 and the immediate east sex
now Queen to d6 bite re Oh black can
black can even capture F captures on e6
and after something like h4 Knight to d7
h5 Bishop to f7 and therefore it's both
playable for white and for black it's
you know simply a matter of personal
choice so after a sex Queen to d6 bite
re he captures on f7 Bishop captures on
f7 and f4 Knight to f6 and Knight to c3
Knight B d7 and Bishop to h3 and here
tari has a lot of options here he can go
something like east sex he can go Queen
to e6 would check maybe what ideas of
exchange in Queens if Oprah would block
with Queen e2 he can go for age six to
maybe block g5 this way but tally goes
for the immediately g5 we have F
characters and g5 and now Knight to e4
and here opera plays Knight G to E -
maybe maybe a better move would have
been to capture this Knight captures
captures but you know it's it's not it's
not at all clear but Oberon went for 90
G to E - we have Bishop to g7 castles
castles by both sides and Bishop to e3
nice to b6 now going for that c4 square
Bishop to f4 would a temple on the Queen
now Knight captures on c3 and B captures
and c3 opening can't capture the Queen
Bishop character 76 because after the
following line Nike after sandy one now
bit of characters on e7 rook rook to e8
rook captures night and d1 and rook
captures Bishop on e7 and after
something like night to g3
operon would be down a piece so this
definitely isn't in whites favor so
after Knight captures and c3b captures
and c3 was played an owwie 5 a beautiful
central thrust
Bishop to g3 and now Knight to c4
the night is finally on c4 and that is
there is no piece that can get him away
from there
rock to f5 and here we have Bishop to g6
probably something operating was
expecting but he thought things would
things would go differently Queen to d3
now the problem with rook captures on f8
would check this is you know you're
getting rid of this problem of Bishop is
attacking rook
but after rook captures and rook
captures after something like Bishop to
g2 Queen to e7 attacking the g5 pawn
queen see one probably defending and
after he captures Knight captures Bishop
captures and C captures the Queen comes
to e2 and this is a much better position
for black you're attacking g4 here
white white will struggle immensely to
defend this the bishop is attacking c2
and the white white doesn't really have
anything here so after this Bishop to g6
Queen to d3 was played operon is kind of
hoping that this Bishop captures rook
and then he can under bow and create
this powerful F and G pawn but Queen to
e7 attacking the g5 pawn we have D
captures on e5 Knight captures on e5 and
now Queen to III and the operands idea
is after Bishop captures rook G captures
Bishop on f5 he will have this threat of
pushing the pawn to f6 but he missed the
Terry's idea
Tyree plays Bishop captures rook on f5g
captures an f5 and now f6 is coming and
he's well I don't think he missed this I
just think there was no way around this
he thought if Queen captures and g5 then
Bishop captures knight on e5 or
something but he missed the this idea
Queen captures and g5 and this is
perfectly fine this is the only move
actually that works for black no other
move gives black the advantage and the
problem is you can't capture if you
capture the Queen Anne I have three
check for King the king and the Queen
and after King g2
Knight captures Queen you're down the
exchange and you're losing this game as
white so after Queen captures
g5 open Android 92 a four rook 88 I
would have Queen to eat two now
operating has to find any means not to
exchange Queens or he can simply resign
the game Knight to g6 now opening up a
discovered attack on the Queen Knight
the e6
okay you are forking the rook and the
Queen but doesn't really matter because
Knight to f4 now the bishop can't
capture the night because it's been
denied can't capture because you lose
the Queen and what do you play here if
you capture the Queen with 95 then knife
captures on h3 with check first Knight
captures and rook captures any two again
you're down the exchange and you can't
play this as white against the
Grandmaster sort of tonight at four
Queen g4 was an attempt and after Knight
captures on h3 Queen captures on h3 and
Queen captures on f5 in this position
Oberon resigned the game as the knight
is attacked on e6 the queen is attacked
on h3 so white has no other option but
to capture the Queen and after and after
we exchange Queens rook captures you
have to move the knight something 94
simply Bishop captures D captures and
again you're up the exchange and you're
up on this is completely winning for
black operating does not wanna play this
game anymore so yeah this is a game from
round 8 I think Terri drew all of his
games until the end in round 9 10 and 11
so you know definitely unimpressed and
impressive performance with with 8 and a
half points very nice so yeah
congratulations to Arya entirely now
Norway has two world champions
you know quite quite a country I don't
know if they still have the the
strongest man in the world I think he
lost the title one year ago but he he
might have regained it who knows
so him I would like to thank Vito
Riviera Phillip Denis Richard Evans
Vincent's Dorner Jack powers Luigi :
as track Ronnie and Keith Cunningham for
a contribution to my channel thank a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon and once again the winners
of the giveaway are in the description
below thank you all